the president just did it again Biden
contradicting himself and his own white
house today after spending the weekend
trying to walk back these comments on
Putin's removal
we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted and democracy and
principles hope and light of decency and
dignity of freedom and possibilities
for God's sake this man cannot remain
power
[Music]
no
wow all right but just hours ago Biden
claiming none of what you just heard him
say is actually true
and I'm not walking anything back the
fact of the matter is I was expressing
the moral outrage I felt toward the way
Putin is dealing in the actions of this
man personal feelings sir
my personal friends the idea that he is
going to do something outrageous because
I called him for what he was and what
he's doing I think is is just not
rational nobody believes we're going to
take down I was going to I was talking
about taking down Putin
nobody would believe that okay so judge
he's it's our fault for like we we
didn't hear any of that other stuff we
just heard him say he cannot remain in
power so that's on us of course he
didn't mean it of course he didn't mean
it because he knows that he's gonna he's
gonna dither and blather us into World
War III uh I mean everything he says is
being listened to by Putin and Putin is
he's in a corner right now when there's
a stalemate in the war you're in a
corner the question is what is Putin
gonna do next and the truth is this guy
is too dangerous to be the president of
the United States and what I want to
know is why does he say to troops just a
few days ago you'll see when you go in
what the what the Ukrainian soldiers are
like everything he says someone comes
back and they clean it up what I want to
know is the question that no one asks
and that is who is issuing the order to
clean it up aside from this thing which
could get us into war in three seconds
because Putin should be outraged and
probably is the the question really is
when it when it when it relates to CDC
when it relates to the Pentagon who
comes in and says all right everybody we
got to walk that statement back who is
in charge in the White House who is the
president
but you know it's not common well she's
got less fewer marbles than he does so
it's a very dangerous time for America
and 71 percent of Americans don't
believe that he is equipped to handle
this you know what Dane I have an
analogy I haven't used one in a while
all right president is like a contestant
on Let's Make a Deal who always turns
down the guaranteed cash and just watch
what's behind door number three and it's
always like a 25 year old donkey tied
tied to a rocking chair he never makes
the right decision you know it's
interesting Kamala Harris might have had
the better trip to Europe yeah and then
she started sitting there thinking like
oh hey I don't look so bad now because
the truth is President Biden by all
accounts a lot of people thought he gave
a pretty good speech and the speech was
written and he gives a speech and then
he ad-libs the nine words now you ask a
very good question
who decided to walk it back because
immediately we're texting I'm like oh my
God I can't believe you said that we
know it because Putin in his mind thinks
that this is going to happen so that's
why he's been using it as an excuse that
you're so provocative and then that
hasn't been our policy gentaki has said
it Tony blinken has said it and then all
of a sudden the President says that
and then White House staffers Anonymous
on background tell the Washington Post
yeah he really screwed up there then you
have him today saying no what I meant
was this now he could have done that on
the plane what I would have done is said
we got a problem sir
this is what they heard you say is that
what you meant no it's not what I meant
okay I'm gonna bring the pool the
reporters into the conference room on
Air Force One you can do it on the
record clarification or whatever they
want to call it to him and put this to
bed that night instead they wait three
days they always do this they wait three
days until it's so solidified in
people's minds and now people are even
more confused
Pierce do you think this Gaff energizes
Putin and his supporters because they
want to believe it's about decapitation
about getting you know getting Putin out
so this just validates that's why it's
so fantastically dangerous yeah as as
the judge said because what it does it
emboldens putum with his own people
because he's been trying to sell them a
message of look the Americans and the
West want to basically take us over what
more evidence do they need now than the
president of the United States on the
record on camera in front of the world's
media representing NATO saying we've got
to remove Vladimir Putin that's what he
said we heard him say it and this thing
I did of him now walking back all the
walk backs I mean I can't remember the
last time I saw a world leader who is
takes time today to walk back the
repeated walkbacks of his own gas and
there are four yeah the minor incursion
gaffe which by the way probably gave
Putin along with the Afghanistan Fiasco
the encouragement he needed to go into
Ukraine the chemical weapons gaffe were
going to respond in kind that means you
use chemical weapons right that had to
be warped back the ground forces Gaff
which you mentioned and then they
removed Putin from Power that's four
times three in the last week where the
president of the United States says
something yeah then his people come out
and say that's not what he said even
though we've just heard him say it and
now he comes out and it's a brass neck
to look down the barrel of a camera to
the American people and go we didn't
walk anything back so not only did you
not hear me say the original thing but
the walk-backs which were then announced
about what I said originally they didn't
exist either in fact we shouldn't have
been walking back any walkbacks about
the walk backs and if you could follow
any of that you're a better man than me
and what I find also about this which is
I think is really unsettling the
desperate ways that the Democrats and
many of the quite liberal skewed
mainstream media go out of their way to
try and defend this you're out of their
way to try and put trade this as
commanding leadership when the polls as
we just heard of crashing to new loads
when confidence in him in trust in
President Biden because of all these
gaffes is collapsing they've got to get
a grip of this because if you can't
trust a word he says mainly because he
can't even remember saying it then
there's a problem this guy's the leader
of the Free World you know uh Jesse
maybe this is a positive spin nobody
really believes what he's saying like
even a world leader is a guy you know
what it's just like he didn't really
mean everybody's it's like they look at
him like Forrest Gump at this point
the media used to mock Reagan right for
being an actor he used to work with
chimpanzees not a traditional resume for
a politician but Reagan was considered
the great communicator because he could
get the script show up on time and
deliver it with gusto and precision
now he was around the same age as Joe
Biden is right now when he was president
we didn't have problems like this like
we're having now Reagan would get up
there and nail it even off prompter he
was steady
to your point the White House needs an
intervention because you can't have
Kamala Come Away with less gaffes after
a trip and as a journalist I can't
believe I'm going to say this am I a
journalist I don't even know if I would
not say that yet but I shouldn't
probably say that but you've crossed the
line I'm gonna have to slap you
she needs to make sure Joe Biden goes up
there
delivers the script on teleprompter and
walks out because you can't have us in a
proxy war with Russia in Europe him
going off script you're giving Putin a
propaganda Victory and you're dividing
NATO so they either need to set aside
longer time and Air Force One to drill
into his brain this is the message this
is what you say and have them have a
little discipline and confidence and I
volunteer to participate in those prep
sessions
that's the solution I'm sure that would
be very welcome hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else